hi everyone I'm Hannah Davis and today
I'm going to be talking to you about
generating music from text and emotion
and other experiments and when I give
this talk I use usually like to talk a
little bit about data sonification first
and data sonification is exactly like
data visualization except instead of
representing data through visuals you're
representing it through sound I'll show
you a few examples of what I mean
[Music]
that's one of my favorites so this next
one is very different it's kind of
basically it's sauna fiying how fast
Olympic athletes cross the finish line
and I love this piece this is by Amanda
Cox who's kind of a legend I love this
piece because if you see this image you
can you can see how fast they are and
you know how close they are together but
when you listen to it the impact is much
stronger this next one is by James
Murphy of LCD soundsystem and this is
different than the other two in that it
takes kind of a lot of components of the
data this is data from tennis matches
and it takes a bunch of these components
like the player names the seeds the
temperature which court they were on and
combines all of those to make kind of a
more atmospheric piece
[Music]
so there are a couple different types of
data sonification the first is ah de
fication and when people get into this
field this is kind of where they start
this is just directly converting data to
sound interpreting data as amplitude
over time but what I'm more interested
in and what I'll be talking about a
little more today are these next two
which are parameter mapping which is
where you're mapping some value of the
data to the component of the sound with
the focus being on highlighting the data
and then music generation which is the
same thing your mapping values of data
to values of the sound but the focus is
not on conveying the data as much as it
is about creating interesting music and
sound has a couple of strengths that
visuals don't necessarily have its
temporal its multi-dimensional it's
really easy to find cycles and patterns
and just finding structure in data it's
good for small units it's good for
streams of data and hearing changes in
streams like the first stock exchange
when we saw it's good for grabbing
attention and humor and finally it's
it's naturally emotional and it moves
the listener so before I continue with
music I want to just talk about my own
background in emotional data I first got
interested in emotional data when I
found this data set maybe five or six
years ago called singularly how did the
candidates make you feel and all this
was was just asking voters how the
presidential candidates made them feel
and when I was prototyping like a data
visualization no matter what I did I
couldn't convey what that question was
really entailing and around the same
time I found out about these Chernov
phases which in data visualization I
think are a little bit look down upon
because it's hard to distinguish the
different parts of data you know you're
mapping different parts of the data to
different features of the face but you
can see this one here is like a not good
one these are these are like applicant
scores so the eyebrows are related to
the autobiography whatever that means
the smile size is related to the
interviews
core and the visualization here is just
not really relevant to the underlying
data but I thought it would be relevant
to the how did the candidates make you
feel and so I ended up mapping this
question to these chair and off phases
and so basically the anger is related to
the slope of the eyebrows the fear was
related to the width the size of the
eyes the pride was related to the length
of the nose and the smile was related to
the width of the mouth and so what that
ended up doing was I think over time
really representing how people felt
about these elections like I was at
Harvard that one but this one was pretty
meh for like everyone you know no one
was really feeling it either way this
one we all remember like very a lot of
extremes woodbush and then of course we
had the Obama Hope time period and then
unfortunately the datasets stopped there
and this is like something they'd been
tracking for ever but I would have loved
to see in this last election or maybe I
wouldn't have we'll see so I was
interested in emotional data for a while
this was me just like tracking my own
facial expressions while browsing the
internet where each second was each each
square was a second and I used this kind
of visualization to do my first
sonification and this was representing
different authors writing styles
[Music]
and I liked this piece a lot because you
really can hear the different writing
styles come through like Hemingway has
no descriptive words at all
[Music]
so I did that project for a while but
ultimately felt like the pieces that
were coming out were too similar and so
I started thinking about like what is
interesting to people about you know
their favorite novels and things like
that and it's the emotions and so I
wanted to make a project where I could
do the same thing but with the emotions
and so I had two questions for myself in
starting out this project and the first
was can I translate emotions between
mediums can I make a piece of music that
has the emotions of a novel and can I
create a musical piece with the same
underlying tone as the novel all
programmatically and so for a few years
I worked on a project called trans trans
prose which is basically a mapping
between text analysis and music
composition and how it works is I'm
using a word emotion association lexicon
to get these splines of emotion counts
throughout the novel and increase I
increase the melodic movement at
particularly emotional points and what
this means is that the plot is created
not in the literal events but in the
emotional representation of the events
and I'll play you a few pieces here but
before I do I want to play you a few
things that went wrong so I can
appropriately set your expectations the
first couple of pieces were missing a
few things including complexity
order
[Music]
and emotional accuracy
this is heart of darkness by Joseph
Conrad
so I fixed that so let me play you a few
and if you'd like you can look at some
of the mappings and try to assess out
parts of the novel but you're also just
welcome to us
[Music]
now on the other end of the spectrum and
then this next one is very different
because the protagonist is doing really
really horrible things in a happy tone
and I think it's captured in the music
[Music]
so I did a couple other projects using
this generating from text structure I
sauna fide the 2016 debates which was
more funny at the time
so overall Clinton was more positive and
active Trump was more negative and
passive but both candidates had high
levels of trust anticipation and fear
which I think makes sense when
discussing the future and I actually
didn't compare them to each other but I
compared them to themselves over the
course of the three debates I'm not
gonna play the whole thing each piece
for you I'll play a little bit just so
you can hear the difference
so the first debate this is Clinton's
first to be this is the baseline
so on the second debate her joy levels
rose
and then on the third debate her fear
levels rose for Trump Pierce's baseline
on the second debate his anger and fear
levels rose
and on the third debate his anger levels
rose above all other emotions
yeah let's move on from that so another
thing I did was a piece called sim
phonology with a French composer and
this was kind of the first time I'd
worked with a human composer and so
basically I created a couple of pieces
based on news articles talking about the
rise of technology over time and he
flesh those out into a full-scale
orchestra so this was a much longer
piece but I'll play you a little clip of
it
[Music]
[Music]
so after this I decided to do a couple
of pieces sorry a couple of pieces that
weren't text-based so this was one of
the first pieces that didn't use the
structure of text to generate music and
I intentionally chose this UFO sightings
data set to see if I could find
structure in a seemingly chaotic data
set and it turns out I can the pattern
in this data set is that most UFO
sightings happen in evening hours so it
creates this nice underlying rhythmic
structure these this is just a sample of
some of the sightings
so this is based on samples but I also
wanted to do a more formal composition
based on it so this is that piece
[Music]
so another thing I've been working on is
trying to generate music from film I'm
kind of creating automatic soundtracks
and this is a project that's still in
the early stages I'll play you just my
first prototype and this was my my
question to myself was basically is it
possible to just create a score using
the note C so I'll show you the results
of that can you turn that up a bit
[Music]
so this is all programmatically
generated based on the content of the
video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so it works better for some genres than
others so one piece I did this spring
that I loved was this piece called
fabrica alta and this is a factory one
of italy's like most well known
industrial factories that had kind of
been abandoned and more recently this
Italian collective d20 kind of revived
it and actually turned it into a musical
instrument and so they've been
commissioning like computer musicians to
generate pieces for it and what was cool
about this project was they they gave me
two sets of samples one of sounds of the
factory as it actually was when it was
actually in use you know like the looms
and the people speaking and footsteps
and things like that and then another
one of children pretending to be the
factory so I used a little bit of
machine learning with this I used just
like some basic clustering to kind of
see where the natural or the the older
and newer sounds combined and use that
to inform some of my decisions and I'll
play you a little bit of this piece so
this was the simulator they provided
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and then this was actually played on the
building which was super cool
so I want to go back to the data for a
second so as I mentioned with transposed
I use this lexicon and I used it for
years without really examining it and
when I finally did I saw this and what
this is implying is that the word
childbirth along with several others was
tagged with no emotions which seemed
weird so this got me really interested
in the idea of subjective data and I'm
still exploring this space but a couple
of ideas and questions that have come up
in this research include you know how do
we incorporate emotions and other
subjective experiences into AI like
especially as AI starts moving into more
complex and personal spaces and
especially when we're modeling things
like personality and other people's life
experiences I'm really into this idea of
artisanal data which is kind of creating
and curating explicitly smaller datasets
to be creative for like artistic machine
learning and I'll show you one of those
in a bit deconstructing objectivity and
datasets in general like what type of
subjectivity do we find in really
commonly used machine learning data sets
how were they created what were the
motivations who ended up tagging these
things that are really informing our
society quite a bit at this point
historical bias I really firmly believe
that data sets create they basically
take a they capture a cultures values in
any certain time so how do we kind of
avoid that bias retention over time is
it possible to update datasets which
brings me to labels you know where did
this data come from what are the
ingredients in the data set what should
the expiration date of this data set be
this is something I'm really interested
in and exploring and of course who will
be allergic to this I think data set
should have labels like food has labels
and along the lines of labels I think
you know exploring creative taxonomies
is another way to explore subjective
datasets you know maybe instead of you
know asking for a gender or something
when you are getting demographics maybe
you ask for you know do you like the
ocean or mountain different more how
many years have you spent in a rural or
City environment you know trying to
change our the way we think about
demographics and things like that so
I've started to do some experiments in
this area and the first is this data set
of emotion tagged landscapes so there's
seven sets of landscapes fields forests
oceans roads lakes cities and mountains
and then eight emotions anger
anticipation joyfully fear disgust trust
surprise sadness and then also none and
so I created a couple thousand images
data set from Flickr and had people
tagged them with CrowdFlower
which is kind of like Mechanical Turk
except I like it slightly better because
it has a slightly tighter feedback loop
between the person who's creating the
job and the person who's tagging it and
the one real big obstacle in creating
this subjective data set was that it's
really hard to ask people to tag
emotions and this is made even harder
because CrowdFlower asks you to make
objective answers so it can weed out
bots and things like that and so I got a
lot of angry people you know you know
how can you say that this is incorrect
and so one thing I ended up doing was
saying that any answer is right as long
as they didn't select none and an
emotion and CrowdFlower also has this
nice like feedback loop where you are
rated by the Tigers so you can know that
you're not just like totally destroying
their lives so some of the results were
really cool like this is this is field
over a couple different emotions you see
the joy field trust field that to anger
fields at the bottom disgust had a lot
of Browns and
means a lot of discussed images were
either swamps or like dirt or water in
places it didn't really seem to belong
fear these are some fear results so we
have like a very obviously scary forest
at the top left here and then a pretty
scary like looming storm and then this
last one actually confused me for a
while until I realized that it's pretty
common to have a fear of just like the
wide open ocean so it was cool that the
Tigers were actually like getting both
visual emotions but also like conceptual
emotions as well and then surprise was
interesting because it had a lot of
bright colors so there were a lot of
things I learned about the data set and
I wanted to try to see if I could just
like transfer the style like could I
actually translate content between
emotions and so I did this using the
Nvidia fast I'll transfer that came out
maybe a year ago so on the top left is
or the top are the two inputs so that's
fear to Joy and the bottom is the output
so this is translating a forest from
fear to joy from joy to fear so the
bottom wants the output that's pretty
scary forest it didn't always work
especially with clouds this is a fear to
trust field and anger to joist city it's
just a little less gloomy joy to fear
forest sadness to joy ocean and then one
thing so the summer I was a scholar at
open AI and I focused on actually seeing
if I could generate landscapes kind of
from scratch like emotional landscapes
from scratch so my question to myself
was can i generate emotional variations
of the same base image and so I'm going
to show you a couple of these and so
each of the rows that I'm about to show
you represents the same set of base
generated images and they're pretty
small images
it because this is just a proof of
concept with a pretty small data set but
as these change if you keep your eye on
one or two of the columns you can see
how they change across emotions so this
is anger anticipation discussed a lot of
browns and greens again fear joy sadness
surprise and trust and I'll show you
quickly a second set I also tried to
generate specific landscapes so these
are generated mountains again angers
very dark anticipation with mountains
was actually not very bright discussed
again a lot of browns and greens sadness
is a little muted and then trust is kind
of calm and then I did the same thing
for generated forests so dark and blacks
and purples for anger lighter
anticipation browns and greens for
disgust darker for fear really bright
for joy a little muted for sadness
brighter colors for surprise and then
calmer for trust so that's it thank you
[Applause]